en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología y debido a la
situación que vivimos a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 nos adaptamos desde
nuestros hogares para llevarles toda la
información
-soy valentina torre sánchez gracias por
acompañarme iniciamos este espacio en
china porque este país tiene cuatro
candidatas a vacuna que ya entraron en
la fase 3 de estudios según los
responsables los fármacos no han
producido efectos secundarios graves
actualmente la investigación y
desarrollo de vacunas en china está en
una posición avanzada para ser más
específicos hay 13 vacunas en fases de
ensayo clínico de las cuales 4 han
entrado en fase 3 10 años
por ahora un total de 60.000 voluntarios
han sido vacunados sin reportes de
reacciones adversas serios lo que lo que
inicialmente sugiere que las vacunas son
seguras hasta este tamaño
con duda marino una de las candidatas a
vacuna calificada como una de las más
esperanzadoras de china es la llamada
corona back desarrollada por la
farmacéutica sinovac biotech que ha sido
probada en varios países uno de ellos es
brasil
allí los análisis se han llevado a cabo
con la supervisión del instituto
butantán uno de los centros de
investigación más grandes de ese país
coronaba a esta pasión por todos sus
procesos y coronaba que está pasando por
todos los procedimientos de seguridad
con seguimiento científico de un grupo
de trabajo además de los investigadores
del instituto butantán intente actuar
hasta el momento los resultados han sido
extremadamente positivos yus ante ambos
ateo presente momento ni decir no hemos
tenido incidentes hasta el momento no se
han presentado reacciones adversas en
estos cerca de 9.000 voluntarios junto
con los doctores y paramédicos que han
participado aquí en brasilia entre
médicos y paramédicos que están sentados
aquí nombres para una parte de la
comunidad científica estos avances
podrían significar que china se
encuentra a la cabeza
de la carrera por la vacuna de kobe 19
pero al mismo tiempo advierten que si
bien es necesario que el fármaco esté
listo pronto también es clave completar
todos los ensayos para garantizar la
seguridad y eficacia
ahora vamos hasta taiwán porque
científicos de este país desarrollaron
lo que llaman una prueba altamente veloz
y segura para detectar el coi 19 que es
un chip eléctrico
la principal ventaja de este chip
semiconductores que puede obtener un
resultado muy confiable en 3 minutos
claro que otras pruebas que ya se usan
pueden tener resultado rápido pero todo
nuestro procedimiento está automatizado
por lo que podemos evitar los falsos
positivos y falsos negativos
la efectividad los resultados hace
posible cuarentenas más cortas para
quienes viajan por negocios
mansito y destruyen los desarrolladores
de este test explican que las muestras
que se utilizan pueden ser de sangre o
saliva lo que significa que cualquier
persona puede tomar su propia muestra y
usar el sensor el sistema funcionaría en
aeropuertos y estaciones de tren donde
las personas necesitan desplazarse
rápido por lo que necesitan pruebas
rápidas y lo hemos comparado con el
autoservicio de mcdonald's
los vehículos no necesitan parar solo en
trasponer la muestra llena son los
documentos y cuando terminas con ellos
los resultados estarán listos así que
los viajeros internacionales no tienen
que esperar por orejas
con estos hallazgos finalizamos este
espacio cambiando de tema y de
continente llegamos a américa y
puntualmente a eeuu porque allí fue
creado un particular robot que tiene la
forma de un delfín el aparato de la
empresa edes innovations fue
desarrollado con características tan
reales que busca reemplazar a los
verdaderos delfines en los parques de
diversiones y así acabar con el encierro
de estos mamíferos en esos lugares
actualmente hay unos 3.000 delfines en
cautiverio que son usados para generar
miles de millones de dólares en
experiencias turísticas
así que claramente hay un interés por
amar y aprender sobre delfines y
queremos usar ese interés y ofrecer
diferentes maneras de enamorarse de
ellos
el robot está fabricado con una piel de
silicona de grado médico lo que hace que
sea altamente similar a la del mamífero
mide 2.5 metros de largo y pesa 250
kilos cada uno de estos delfines cuesta
entre 3000 y 5000 dólares y la intención
de la empresa responsable es crear una
especie de programa infantil submarino
en el que los niños aprendan a
relacionarse con los robots delfines
todos quieren saber sin usar un delfín
animatrónico es diferente a usar un
delfín real la verdad es que en muchos
campos es lo mismo si quieres diseñar un
programa o espectáculo usando delfines
reales tienes que capturarlos y
entrenarlos y acostumbrar los con estos
robots tienes que hacer exactamente lo
mismo la diferencia es que no tienes que
dedicarte a la cría de animales
así concluimos esta crónica cuídense si
es posible quédense en casa recuerden
que la salud es lo más importante
gracias por su compañía y continúen con
más en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]